لكن ما هي اهم بنود مبادره المبعوث الاممي
الى ليبيا تنص مبادره باتيل على انشاء
لجنه توجيهيه رفيعه المستوى بهدف اجراء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه خلال
العام الجاري وستعمل اليه المقترحه على
الجمع بين مختلف الاطراف الليبيه بمن فيهم
ممثلون والمؤسسات السياسيه وزعماء القبائل
ومنظمات المجتمع المدني والاطراف الامنيه
وكذلك ممثلون عن النساء والشباب اللجنه
المقترحه ستعمل ايضا على تيسير اعتماد
اطار قانوني وجدول زمني ملزم لاجراء
الانتخابات كما توفر اللجنه منصه لتعزيز
الاجماع حول قضايا تامين الانتخابات
واعتماد ميثاق شرف لجميع المرشحين هذا
بالاضافه الى انشاء الياء بقياده ليبيه
تجمع اصحاب المصلحه للاتفاق على اولويات
الاتفاق وضمان
الانفاق وضمان اداره عائدات النفط والغاز
بطريقه شفافه ومنصفة
معنا من طرابلس مراسل للجزيره احمد خليفه
احمد اذا مبادره عرضنا بنودها لكن ضعنا في
مجمل ما قاله باتيلي اليوم والخطوات
المرتقبه
حقيقه عبد الله بتيلي لم يتحدث عن تفاصيل
تشكيل هذه اللجنه التوجيهيه التي
ستخرج بقاعده دستوريه لاجراء الانتخابات
المقبله ولكنه قال ان هذه اللجنه لن
تختارها الامم المتحده بل ستختارها اطراف
الازمه بشكل عام بما فيها مجلس النواب
والاعلى للدوله واللواء المتقاعد خليفه
حفتر وكافه الاطراف السياسيه في البلاد
وقال ان هذه اللجنه ستقوم باجراء حوارات
بين هذه الاطراف وسيكون ما توافق عليه
مجلس النواب والاعلى في وقت سابق سيكون
اوسع تبني عليه هذه اللجنه عملها وستبني
عليه نتائج عملها التي ستتوج في النهايه
بوضع قاعده دستوريه وخارطه الطريق تجرى
وفقا لها الانتخابات المقبله لكن بتيته
حقيقه لم يتحدث
كيفيه اختيار هذه اللجنه كيف ستختار
تحديدا من الاطراف السياسيه الموجوده في
البلاد وايضا لم يتحدث عن عدد اعضاء هذه
اللجنه حسب ما علمنا ان هناك افكار عده
متداوله امام باتيلي لوضع عدد معين لهذه
اللجنه ايضا وفق ما علمنا من بديل وايضا
من مصادرنا ان هذا المقترح او ما اعلنه
باتيلي اليوم من تشكيل لجنه توجيهيه
بالتعاون مع بقيه الاطراف السياسيه هي
خلاصه لكافه المقترحات التي قدمت لباتيري
في وقت سابق من كافه الاطراف السياسيه
وكافه الاطياف السياسيه
والشبابيه ومنظمات المجتمع المدني
والمرشحين الرئاسيين والبرلمانيين الذين
قدموا مقترحاتهم لعبد الله بتيلي لانهاء
الازمه في البلاد ايضا في خلال حديثه قال
عبد الله بتيلي انه طلب من اطراف الازمه
الذين التقاهم من جميع الاطياف طلب منهم
صراحه تقديم مقترحاتهم لحل الازمه وقال
بما فيهم اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر ايضا
طلبت منه عندما التقيته طلبت منه مقترحا
او مقترحه لحل الازمه في البلاد الان عبد
الله بتيلي في هذه الاحاطه التي انتهت منذ
قليل في هذه القاعه التي تظهر خلفي لم
يحدد تواريخ محدده معينه لعمل هذه اللجنه
لم يتحدث عن اجل معين لاجراء الانتخابات
قال ان الانتخابات ستجرى خلال هذا العام
في خلال ما تبقى من شهر مارس وحتى شهر
ديسمبر المقبل هذا العام
2023 وقال ان القوانين الانتخابيه التي
ستجرى وفقا لها الانتخابات
ستتوافق عليها
هذه اللجنه بالمشاركه مع بقيه الاطراف
السياسيه لكنه كما ذكرت لم يضع اجل
وتواريخ محدده لعمل هذه اللجنه ولم يضع
ايضا اجال وتواريخ محدده لخارطه الطريق
التي
ستنهي المراحل الانتقاليه الموجوده فيها
البلاد اشكرك جزيلا الشكر احمد خليفه
مراسلنا من طرابلس